hey guys and welcome back to City
skylines today there is of course a
number of things I wanted to do but the
main thing that I wanted to get into was
to try another small neighborhood with
the Swedish houses and see how they
would work not just focus on those
Swedish houses themselves but also try
different things with the road layouts
and see actually get some playgrounds
and things like that in there and just
play more with that idea before I
actually get into the larger
neighborhoods that I want to eventually
replace the existing neighborhoods or
many of the existing neighborhoods with
the Swedish grow houses just because it
seems more realistic and this is
something that I'm certain I talked
about more in the future that sounds
weird but I want to replace some of the
older looking neighborhoods in the city
with more of these very modern Phoenix
looking parts under the assumption that
the city is built as a sort of
designated growth area in the 90s which
is how it could technically have a very
old center but basically just be all new
city around that and following that I
want to get rid of all the 70s 80s
looking neighborhoods and just make this
all as modern looking as possible and a
couple of smaller things too I wanted to
work on a couple of offices over here
just to fill up this space I suppose and
yeah this is where I actually cut into
the houses here and basically it is a
very small space and I was thinking for
a while that I might also leave it empty
but it felt way too close to the sort of
central office zone of the city to
actually just keep this field empty but
it was also it's also very compact to
actually fit an area with houses in so
in the end I sort of divided them into
two parts and the playgrounds and Parks
are going to be in the middle quite
curvy roads as you do often see with
these more modern road types all mostly
that's what I like about getting 90s or
later neighborhoods in the Netherlands
is that there's a lot of freedom in how
you place the road so there's no exact
pattern to do it and there are many
different shapes that you can go
though I do have to say and this is
something that I don't know how to
pronounce his name but at this I'll
probably put a link in the description
he's got some amazing stuff too but once
mentioned something about that some
cities are really built from like a
bird's eye perspective from top but not
really figuring that actual humans are
gonna live there and I kind of wanna and
I suppose this sort of fits into the
entire idea of new Dutch neighborhoods I
kind of want to get the best of both
worlds in that case I yes I do really
want to plan the city as a whole sort of
and work with just have fun with
different Road shapes and get that in
but definitely also focus on these
smaller things and make sure that I get
enough playgrounds in and make this not
entirely look like a communist block of
flats and that's sort of what I'm gonna
try to do I'm not sure how well it
really succeeded in the end but yeah
that is the basic idea for this small
area and that's also sort of why I
wanted to get these interesting shapes
in a way and wanted to not just have
straight roads but have some curves in
there but also leave some space for
playgrounds and also have foliage and
other things like that this is probably
if you look at it that way the best
neighborhood in the city figuring how
much park it has per houses and well I
do have to say I am not quite messing
yet with two different with too many
different types of houses there are many
different houses in the Swedish royal
house back and I definitely want to
switch up the style of houses as I go
through the city but so far I just kind
of took two houses to try so far and I
think it really succeeded but
realistically yeah I really do want to
switch it up a little bit in the future
what you do very commonly see in Dutch
cities is that especially in these newer
neighbors like all the neighbourhoods
would still use row houses for a large
area that looked largely the same but
especially in recent years there's been
a trend that everybody wants to live in
their unique houses and how to switch up
a lot more especially in the last
couple of years now often like rows of
row houses where every day every house
has different bricks and different
colors and things like that that is
something which I can't go into but at
least I want to switch it up a little
bit more than it used to be in the city
and also and this is probably something
I should mention since it's quite a big
change to the city overall I do wanna
change the foliage so far I've been
having a autumn theme and I've probably
complained enough about it but as much
as I like autumn as anything for foliage
it just doesn't really work I think in
this game since realistically I'd want
to have no trees that are largely green
if it's early in in the autumn but I
have a couple of yellow or orange leaves
and sort of they're sort of partially
turning into autumn colors but now it's
just the case that some trees are
completely summer and some trees are
like late fall and 100% red and you
can't really make a distinction and make
smooth transitions with trees that kind
of are both green and have some yellow
leaves and sort of start deteriorating
so I think I'll just what actually I
will just switch it up into a complete
summer theme whatever you think of it I
suppose I can't really turn back at this
point but just so you know this is the
last episode sort of with these trees
and at the end of this episode I don't
really have a real-time parts but it was
requested that I actually added some
night shots so I had a couple of those
and some some shots that were lowered
from the ground as well not just really
overview shots and that's where you'll
see that I'll actually have no awesome
colors in the city anymore so that's a
quite a big change I also might want to
stop switching up all the different
trees in the future because as much as
it's fun to place different types of
trees and mess with all sorts of colors
and shapes
it isn't really quite too realistic
especially in these environments where
trees are just massively planted and one
go to sort of provide sound barriers and
things like that or make parks you
usually see this same type of the same
type of tree in really large flocks and
don't
have done in the city yet since at the
moment especially with these autumn
trees it's just all kinds of trees and
bushes all over the place and as
counterintuitive as it sounds I want to
switch up the different types of trees a
little less in the future and remove
some different types of trees to keep it
a little bit more homogeneous just
because that makes more sense in a
natural sense I would this by the way
was one of the reasons why I kind of was
very not so willing to get into the
Swedish rowhouses because since I really
wanted to have the backyard idea with
the offense with the little paths behind
the houses this would mean that I would
have to place all my fences myself and
actually fence of all the different
areas for the houses and their gardens
myself which partially it was a bit of
an annoying job to do and it takes a lot
of time for all the houses and I would
like to say that is actually why I am
using hedges over here if you Dutch
you're probably screaming stop using
hatches it's a little bit more realistic
to actually have gone in fences rather
than hedges but I just tried it there
you could see that and no I don't think
I'm gonna try it since basically the
hatches is I mean the fences are very
thin and you can't really stack them
since the texture will come out weird
and hatches are just so much better and
easier to work with that I think I'll
just go with hatches for all the houses
over here to divide their gardens
normally you would sort of see a mixture
of hatches and fences here and there but
I'll just keep it to almost only hatches
in this case just because it's a little
easier to work with
so yeah I'm bear that in mind but I will
get into some slight details at least to
make sure that these backyards at least
have a bit of a yawn and touch touch to
them and other than nuts I really only
just wanted to place a couple of trees
here in there the houses themselves come
with small terraces and I mean that's
not even a good translation of a Dutch
word they call they come with small like
lavish sets and tables and picnic tables
and things like that and I think
sometimes even like like playground
equipment and stuff in the backyard so
that should be fine I just wanted to
demarcated backyards a little bit more
clear and a little bit more in a touch
type of sense and yeah that was pretty
much what I wanted to do up there I also
just wanted to add a little bit more
foliage over here since it was looking a
bit too bare for my liking though I do
have to say I might bear the entire city
up a little bit since it's a very common
pitfall to just fill up foliage until
it's all filled up I suppose but I try
to keep at least some more open areas
and keep more grass here and there and
as hard as it is sometimes I think I'll
just open some areas up a little bit
more especially this around this older
part like especially around the parts
that I built first like an episode one
like the houses that you see over here
are there's so many trees around them
and I think it would actually benefits
from making that area way less dense and
also adding some grassy fields here and
there so that's something that I want to
move into the future too
also small disclaimer about this
district it's gonna be completely gone
in the next episode I don't know why I'm
saying it right now but yeah next
episode I'm just gonna completely
flatten this area and start that all
over just so you know but yeah this is
pretty much all just fixing up of the
city so I suppose I can talk a bit about
the future of the city that like the
oldest part is not the only part that
when I remove and I also want to remove
this part with Iran about eventually and
what else do I wanna do well rework the
foliage of the entire city of easly and
I got rid of the entire autumn theme is
something that I'll do in the future
but there's also some new things that I
do want to get to I will get a football
stadium on the other side of the highway
is where I want to have it and also on
the other side of the highway I want to
eventually get a train yard going kind
of based around the train yard which is
very close to where I live it won't be
too big but it's something then I kind
of wanted to get in there
and very close to that is gonna be
another neighborhood and also the
University of the city now a very
pressing issue which I still haven't
even gotten to and not speaking from a
couple of episodes ahead is the center
of the city and what I see I see all of
the comments about whether I'm gonna get
a historic center and yes I definitely
will i well obviously given the shape of
the center of the city as it came with
this map I do really want to make one of
the starch fortified city centers
especially in the style of William stop
or nada
something like that is definitely what I
want to do but so far I just don't
really feel like I dare to tackle it yet
but the general plan for that is to get
a hill around the star-shaped
island in the middle and I only want to
have city walls or at least a couple of
them around the edges at the entrance
roads not actually around the island
itself usually the walls are long gone
and they're replaced with little hills
in the shape of the old walls so I
definitely want to have that in here as
well but maybe a couple of small ports
small entrance tower things arches would
be pretty cool I think and inside of
that I'll just get a grid going with the
some of the touch ish looking buildings
that I found on the interwebs and
hopefully that should eventually look
somewhat good maybe a of course a couple
of little squares and churches but
that's something I'll get in at a very
late stage it is something that I do
intend to do in the future
but not in the very near future since I
just kinda want to practice and mess
with the idea before actually tackle the
city center just so it doesn't go
terribly wrong
and yeah that's pretty much my plan for
that now over here and this is probably
why in hindsight this might have been a
waste of time quite honestly I finally
got to what I wanted to do for quite a
long time and make this cauliflower
neighborhood stand on its own a little
bit more so at some parks alongside the
edges but also a dike around it but I
might eventually just end up removing
the entire cauliflower neighborhood and
I say I might but I may probably very
well end up doing that since I just
don't feel like it fits into the city
like it probably said before so yeah
this is a pretty temporary thing I might
I may very well get back to the
cauliflower neighborhood style if I
continue this map for long enough and if
my computer will be able to take that
but I'll try it in different towns like
surrounding this area I definitely want
to have some smaller towns and towns
that are not per se entirely planned and
dedicated like growth centers where
people are supposed to live but you know
some of the other towns that would still
have cauliflower neighborhoods as well
some small historic centers that it's
definitely something then I do want to
get into in the future as well and yeah
I just kind of wanted to mess with this
River as well for a little bit and get
nice around it since it didn't have that
which is one of the biggest issues when
it comes to the realism of the city
really and it's something that I can't
really do much about or actually I might
do something about that but basically
the island is not actually lower than
the river and that sort of just beats
the entire realism of a Dutch city I
mean the land is not that much higher
than the water level and there's still
are dikes around the main river but I
eyes do still feel like I'm missing that
main sort of realism aspect of the land
actually being lower than the water
level of the river and I've been
struggling with water sources for a very
long time because I've wondered I have
been wanting to integrate a lot of more
okay if I can actually talk for a second
I have been wanting to integrate more
water into and whatever I'm building
since there is so much water in the
nether
just from ditches to small lakes to
decorate neighborhoods and things like
that so I do want to go get into it and
I actually experimented with the water
sources quite a bit and finally
understand how they actually work which
took way too long but I should perhaps
be able to add extra water sources to
the river to make the water level of
that a bit higher and maybe eventually
get the city below the water level of
the river that would be really awesome
eventually but those are plans for far
ahead in the future for now it's just
gonna be a plan to add more water here
and there at the B flat plains of the
city and add some extra canals and small
lakes and stuff like that
with some simple water sources and that
should be alright in the future over
here I just wanted to add a small little
neighborhood just to make sure that
because I wanted to have a park over
here just to make sure that the park
wouldn't be too ridiculously large so I
just wanted to quickly have this here
but next to this I'm gonna build a park
pretty soon and I think that's next
episode stuff anyway this is where I
wanted to add a couple of shots I don't
actually have a real time thing recorded
for this episode and you'll notice
actually that this was recorded after a
while after this episode as well since
this is actually where I removed all of
the autumn trees so all of the trees
agree now I personally like it more just
a bit more realistic like I've said
before yeah that's pretty much the only
really noticeable change over here and
this is just how I figured I could make
a reasonable skyline that would at least
be impressive to look at but still
somewhat believable for a city disc this
size given that the city is still gonna
grow quite a bit more and that the well
the accounts of City skylines isn't
quite realistic since this game fits
like 30 people in a large apartment
building which could otherwise fit 200
people in it so I do have quite a bit
more population than this game actually
suggests and yeah that's I have gotten
some requests to actually get the
realistic populations mod which I have
right before but it tends to either [ __ ]
up your infrastructure since it's pretty
much built around the population I have
right now and since the city is mostly
built out of row houses and those aren't
really affected by the by the more to
much I don't think it would make too
much of a difference anyway this is a
[ __ ] this is a [ __ ] what this is a shot
which I really love in here the only
thing that I would say about it is that
there are way too many lights in the
farmlands because I still forgot for
many of these small concrete paths to
remove the lights on it and I might also
remove the lights on some of those roads
that go to houses because quite honestly
you wouldn't have that many lights
Netherlands likes to light up a lot and
have many lights but this is a bit
ridiculous though realistically I should
turn off the highway lights at midnight
through something like that but that's
not something I can do oh and this is
the sunrise shot sort of following the
main road which still goes through the
city which I really just took to because
I think it looks cool also something
that I should probably say is that I do
intend to in the future get the
first-person mode using which or like
some of the modes using which you can
follow vehicles like trains and cars and
make some videos of that but I want to
get into things like that once the city
is more finished also the buildings on
the left over here have disappeared I
don't know why but I need to replace
those but yeah I definitely want to go
into car POVs and train POVs and stuff
like that eventually and not just have
these cinematic shots because they might
get old after a while and in the end I
think real-time footage is just as good
at showing off what the city looks like
it's just that I didn't have real-time
footage recorded for this so next
episode I should have it again anyway
thanks for watching guys and I'll
wiedersehen I suppose